welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and the batman tests this year two
detective with a riddler who comes off
like the guy at a game night who poorly
explains the rules and then just starts
singing falsetto church songs hey
spoilers ahead because while we weren't
led to believe the riddler might have
known that batman and bruce wayne are
the same person in a great twist he
suddenly implies that he doesn't
actually know batman's identity what a
twist but new evidence does leave enough
up for interpretation that by the
movie's ending the riddler might
actually know batman's identity and
spoke the name bruce wayne to threaten
batman making it even more worrisome
that this creepy know-it-all is now
making friends i'm gonna break down what
the riddler knew and when he knew it
based on the evidence laid out in this
batman film and our friends at short
boxed are giving away the silver age
appearance of penguin from 1963 stick
around to the end of this video to learn
how to enter to win so when the batman
and the riddler first meet face to face
in arkham the riddler smiles and says i
told you i'd see you in hell referring
to the note in the fireproof bag
attached to the explosive that he sent
to wayne tower and then the riddler
monologues if only you knew how long i
was waiting for this day for this moment
i've been invisible my whole life i
guess i won't be anymore will i they'll
remember me now they'll remember both of
us and take it away paul dano bros
way
and at this moment batman eyes the
security camera is recording this
conversation panicking that the city
authorities will now know his identity
but trying his best not to show that on
his face and then the riddler rants
about being present when thomas wayne
promised his renewal fund how he
suffered a bleak childhood watching rich
orphan bruce wayne get all the attention
instead and then the riddler comes back
to the name bruce wayne bruce wayne he's
the only one we didn't get but we got
the rest of them didn't we and that
snaps batman and snaps us back to
reality right of course the riddler
could not have known batman and bruce
wayne were the same person right because
after killing mayor mitchell and
commissioner savage and d.a coulson the
riddler's next target was going to be
the billionaire bruce wayne the bomb
that alfred opened was meant for bruce
and the rhythm included in that a
fireproof envelope containing the see
you in hell note that was intended for
batman to discover after bruce's death
so you would think for matt to different
people right and all these events unfold
in under a week so the riddler had to
perfectly time his attacks and mail out
that letter bomb for bruce so he really
wouldn't have had much time to alter his
plan halfway through so it's safe to
assume at least that the riddler at
least went into this assuming that bruce
wayne was a separate person from the
batman that bruce wayne was one of his
corrupt targets but that batman was a
separate identity that the riddler saw
as an inspiration part of his team a
masked vigilante who like him used fear
to force gotham to change and the
riddler even said it didn't matter to
him who was under the mask because the
mask is the identity indeed from a
literalist interpretation when he tells
batman they'll remember me now they'll
remember both of us bruce wayne by us he
didn't mean himself and batman he meant
himself and bruce wayne the other orphan
at the top of his mind in this moment
and he's just repeating the name bruce
wayne to mock the media who repeated
this other orphan's name over and over
again who got all the attention this is
like jan brady saying marsha marsha
marsha
marshall
marshall why did you say that dad
persuade persuade bruce wayne but there
is a reason why batman was so fooled in
this moment and it's because there
really is nothing to indicate at first
that the riddler's context shifted from
batman and we know the context was all
batman at first because he said i told
you i'd see you in hell if only you knew
how long i was waiting for this day for
this moment nothing to indicate that he
then shifted to bruce wayne at first
like paul dano a really good actor
deliberately takes no pregnant pause he
signals no transition of thought he just
maintains his calm steady demeanor and
that's why this misdirect worked on us
grammatically the antecedent is vague
now sure you could argue that the
riddler just has a damaged mind and he
rambles from one subject to the next
without notice but this movie stated
that he does not make grammatical
mistakes like this we learned that the l
versus law mistake was actually an
intentional clue leading batman to url
ratalata.com so the riddler must have
known that his phrasing would lead to
some confusion i mean re-watch this clip
he is clearly savoring saying the name
bruce wayne using it to see what kind of
reaction he'll get from the guy across
the glass from him riddler does not seem
confused here he is clearly in control
and that brings me back to the carefully
pre-laid steps of the riddler's plan
there was one step however that does not
make much sense the orphanage the
orphanage when batman and gordon
misinterpreted el rata elata to mean the
penguin and overlooked that law versus l
clue the riddler on his website wrote
intrustone and said he needed to show
them more and then used that orphan
riddle to lead them to the orphanage but
if you think about it this was a really
unusual step in the riddler's plan
because every other time he followed
where his targets would already be
killed them and then left love letters
for batman at the scenes of those crimes
to give him more information and also
all of those steps involved either
publicizing the depth of the media or
releasing a ton of information in the
media right afterward they were all very
public events the orphanage is
completely private arguably the only
people who knew that the riddler did
anything there were just batman and
gordon the riddler lured batman to this
remote orphanage where he set it up to
be this kind of haunted house he painted
all over the walls phrases like where it
all began sins of the father renewal was
a lie and then projects in the ballroom
this video of thomas wayne's renewal
fund promise and really in terms of the
plot of this movie this scene just
teases information to batman that he was
going to learn anyway from the crooked
cop kenzie and from the thomas martha
arkham secrets video that the riddler
already planned to release to the public
it was the allegations in that video not
the stuff learned from the orphanage
that led bruce to falcone and really it
was selena brought kinsey to them to
reveal falcone was the true winged rat
boss so looking back the orphanage was
either an insanely hastily assembled
redundant backup step to course correct
batman to follow the money or a
completely unnecessary step in the
riddler's plan except the orphanage
actually served one key function in this
plot and needed to be in this movie
because it made certain that batman was
not in wayne tower at the time of the
explosion and to prove to riddler that
if bruce wayne a shut-in who supposedly
never leaves his tower if he survived
that blast that batman and bruce wayne
were probably the same person now the
riddler might not have known for sure at
first that bruce wayne was batman but by
luring batman away from wayne tower to
that orphanage where he could confront
him with the wayne family's dark secrets
he could be sure that batman slash bruce
would receive the see you in hell note
after the blast and continue to join him
in his mission but make it look like he
was trying to kill bruce wayne and now
that the riddler knows this truth he
would have some leverage over him
therefore i think it's a completely
valid interpretation that the riddler
did know that batman was bruce wayne
that he carefully rehearsed his speech
to batman and arkham with intentionally
vague grammar to initially scare him
into thinking he knew his identity but
then at the right moment backpedal and
play dumb so that then he could try to
appeal to batman's fractured identity
make him feel super guilty for his
privileged spoiled past and to let go of
that pass to embrace his new identity of
the masked monster and join riddler in
his purge of the city's true evil now
that much yeah as we saw was a total
reach for him to expect so riddler
needed something to threaten batman with
and that thing it's just enough paranoia
that the riddler might know batman's
biggest secret and could at any point
share it with the cops or with any of
the jokers in the neighboring cells and
as a meta clue to us the viewers this
movie showed the riddler including the
word hush in his doctored video which i
think was a clue for us pointing to the
hush comic storyline which ends
similarly with riddler in prison where
the riddler proves that he knows batman
is bruce wayne but batman responds a
riddle that everyone knows the answer to
is worthless a point that the riddler
has to concede finally learning to hush
himself now again what makes the scene
so great is that it does not explicitly
state either way how much the riddler
knows and really leaves it mostly on our
interpretations of paul dano's acting
but it remains true that there is enough
in this movie to indicate that the
riddler could have deduced the truth and
that vagueness is the point the best
riddler is one who leaves us with more
questions and again we are partnering
with short box to give away a rated copy
of batman issue 155 from 1963 the first
silver age appearance of the penguin
it's got a great cover by shelley moldov
and it is currently valued at over 500
short boxed is the easiest and safest
way to buy and sell graded comic books
you can download short box for free on
ios and android they have an incredible
selection of graded comics they have
everything from recent favorites to the
first appearance of the x-men or
spider-man some of the most valuable
comics in the world all orders are fully
protected and insured for buyers and
sellers thousands of the most respected
dealers and collectors in the industry
trust shortbox and use it every day so
to enter the giveaway visit
shortboxed.com new rockstars to enter
and receive a promo code for 15 off your
first short boxed order again that's
shortboxed.com new rockstars you can
check out our gotham noir shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at avos subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis and
everything you love thanks for watching
batman
[Music]
you